[MUSIC PLAYING]
KYLE MCDONALD: Hey, I'm Kyle.
MANNY TAN: I'm Manny.
JESSIE BARRY: Hi, I'm
Jessie from the Cornell
Lab of Ornithology.
MANNY TAN: This is
an experiment we
made that uses machine
learning to organize thousands
of bird sounds into an
interactive visualization.
JESSIE BARRY: Bird
sounds can be really
difficult to learn because there
are so many species out there.
And some of them
sound really similar.
And at times, you
might just need
to be distinguishing between
a note that slurs up--
[BIRD CALL]
--or a note that drops in pitch.
And these can be really,
really subtle differences.
MANNY TAN: This
project started when
we were talking to
people at Cornell
about how it might be
interesting to apply machine
learning to bird sounds.
So we decided to
try a little test
with some of the sounds
in their collection.
We didn't give the computer
any outside data or tags
or even tell it
the birds' names.
We wanted to see if it could
just listen to the sounds
and automatically learn its
own way to organize them.
[BIRD CALL]
KYLE MCDONALD:
Birdsongs vary a lot.
So before we can look at
them in the same space,
we have to break down everything
in short bursts of sound,
less than a second long.
[BIRD CALL]
Then we group sounds with
a technique called t-SNE.
First, the computer
creates a fingerprint
from each sound,
which is like an image
or set of numbers
that represents
that particular sample.
Then t-SNE compares all
of these fingerprints
and places similar
sounds closer together.
One way to think about
t-SNE is that it's
taking these fingerprints
from a high dimensional space,
that space with more
than three dimensions,
and reducing them
to two dimensions
so that we can visualize it.
MANNY TAN: And our tests
worked pretty well.
This is a map of the sounds
that the computer created.
You can see that it figured
out how to group similar sounds
from similar birds
closer together.
We also made it so that you
can search for specific birds.
[OWLS HOOTING]
We put it on the
web [INAUDIBLE].
JESSIE BARRY: We certainly
have a dream that someday you'd
be able to put out a microphone
in the Amazon with a recorder
and have all the species,
maybe not even just
birds, identified.
And we will be able to monitor
species diversity at a site
through the automated
recognition techniques.
I think it's incredibly
exciting to figure out
what are those
collaborations that we
can make between computer
science and ornithology
or biology in general and
start to tackle some really
exciting and challenging science
and conservation questions.
MANNY TAN: Visit
mcauleylibrary.org
for more resources
on wildlife sounds.
And you can play with the
experiments we made and get
the code at g.co/aiexperiments.